je m'appelle suis anna canal j 21 ans
et là j'ai fait le boulot de mes rêves
au new york post ont tout pourquoi tu
souris comme ça dès le matin c'est
anormal et écoeurant tu as l'air
ridicule ça va vous allez interviewer ce
sénateur des rues la semaine prochaine
en régie tissu ou pas je sais qu'on peut
toujours compter sur vous j'avais toute
ma vie devant moi
[Musique]
il n'avait absolument aucune idée de ce
qui m'attendait
tu es super à la cour alors magne toi de
ramener ton cul parce que tu va ramer la
réunion j'ai super mal à la tête je suis
malade j'ai mal au ventre et mes mains
sont engourdis
je me suis encore jamais senti que ça
[Musique]
nous avons testé susanna pour toutes les
maladies d'origine infectieuse tous les
résultats ont été négatifs
retrouvez ce qui va pas ensemble son
électro encéphalogrammes est totalement
normal comme son et rennes où tous les
examens neurologiques qu'on lui a fait
tout est normal
son état ne cesse de se dégrader
comportement maniaque de la paranoïa
chacun a son propre diagnostic
qu'aurélie muller ensuite on nous parle
de schizophrénie après de psychose nous
devrons nous adresser à des hôpitaux qui
sont mieux équipés pour traiter ce genre
de problème ce traitement
elle a besoin de tous jusqu'à ce que
nous ayons la réponse
la vie de ma fille est entre vos mains
un petit mois ce qui se passe avec ma
fille je me suppose que vous êtes
suzanne à qui je sais qu'elle est
toujours là juste pris au piège
je vais tout faire pour réussir à vous
sauver non
le tour est essentielle sophie bonjour